all right there you go the far left
threatening riots if they don't get
their way a progressive Congressman
making this threat if President Biden
and Republicans dare cut a penny of
spending during the debt ceiling
negotiations
I think there would be a huge backlash
from our entire uh house Democratic you
know caucus certainly the progressives
but also in the streets you know I mean
I think that this is it's important that
we don't take steps back from a very
strong agenda that the president himself
shepherded so if that kind of extreme
rhetoric sounds familiar it's because it
should it is Democrats also seem to
resort to apparent threats anytime
things get contentious remember Chuck
Schumer warning the Supreme Court about
abortion
I want to tell you Gore such I want to
tell you Kavanaugh you have released the
Whirlwind and you will pay the price
you won't know what hit you if you go
forward with these awful decisions
they did so why hasn't President Biden
condemned his own parties crazy talk
when he's always so quick to get them
Republicans for their I guess Maga
Republicans
the major Republicans represented
extremism that threatens the very
foundations of our Republic the extreme
set of Maggie Republicans has chosen to
go backwards full of anger violence hate
and division the Maggie Republicans
don't just threaten our personal rights
and Economic Security
they're a threat to our very democracy
all right so threats of Plenty but Dana
I think you could pick up what I've
picked up if you really as smart as I
think you are
that the threat is really at Joe Biden's
team they're not they're in a huge box
because they underestimated Kevin
McCarthy they never came to the table
now he's got a 60 40 issue meaning that
60 of the country agrees with where the
Republicans are the Biden team has
nowhere to go and they keep saying
things like well then use the 14th
amendment that is actually not going to
work then they'll threaten violence well
actually that's not going to work either
the CNN poll last night said 60 of
Americans want spending cuts with the
debt ceiling Biden is at a 60
disapproval overall and is 65 percent
disapproval on the economy the other
thing is last night political Playbook
had this piece about Democratic
operatives they're Furious that the
media is covering this the wrong way
because they are not referring to
Republicans as terrorists for pushing
spending cuts it's pretty hard to
imagine that they are pushing this even
though they know that these are not
numbers that we made up these are just
the polling numbers and it's interesting
for Kevin McCarthy to be so
underestimated again and again and how
cohesive they are they weren't even this
cohesive during the Obama years when we
last went through this and remember what
was on the table then sequestration that
took money away from the defense
department that's not on the table now
and I think that because our adversaries
are also watching very closely for
example China who is ready to tell all
of the countries that we are competing
for affections with that the United
States is not a reliable partner that is
pressure that the president of the
United States should heed come to the
table get it done Jimmy I'm just stunned
that the president didn't look at the
calendar the G7 was important those two
countries to go visit after extremely
important he should have been saying
look this is what I want but what's
possible after all he has wisdom because
he's been doing this so long he's got
wisdom so he should have seen this wall
about he's about to run into this wall
why didn't he and do you think that he
has changed his stance and negotiations
because the press conferences like that
well I think with the speaks to is just
how out of touch the people running this
Administration really are and what I
mean by that is when you're making the
case for unlimited spending with 32
trillion dollars in debt you're doing it
in the country where 70 of people are
living paycheck to paycheck the reason
the CNN polling is reflective of people
wanting a little bell tightening because
that's their reality and they know
things don't get better for them if
inflation goes up because of what
they're doing in Washington so that's
why they didn't read the room properly I
don't necessarily attribute this to
Biden because I think what they've done
with him in terms of damage control is
they're trotting him out there with one
Relentless message the message is always
Maga Ultra Maga mega mega I Can't
Believe It's Not Maga and that's
basically what he does okay but let's
quickly acknowledge that if any
Republican said we will take to the
streets this is a full-on Insurrection
mode fences are going up the Capitol
Police are flooding every Avenue in D.C
and that's the part that's so annoying
to me is that when there's a double
standard when it comes to political Vons
no standard if a republican drinks
Hawaiian Punch they're like oh punch
that's code for violence right that's so
right right and by the way uh it is
really good but not good for you
Hawaiian punches that's so true it's not
really uh so yeah so judge the president
and excuse me kept McCarthy in many ways
one already I wanted a clean debt
ceiling race nobody thinks he's getting
it it's getting back to 2022 spending
what's wrong with that it's only last
year oops what's wrong with that is you
put trillions into it in the meantime
and repurposing pandemic spending well
there's no question that Kevin McCarthy
seems like the reasonable person here
that's why Americans are supporting him
you know you don't have to get into the
weeds to understand this you really
don't it's about not spending money that
we don't have and so it's recognizing
that you know what we don't need to keep
making money it's AOC said we can just
print some more and we've got to be able
to support what we can support and
forget about
um you know carrying on with this
incredible indebtedness that's going on
but the thing that concerns me is what I
I wrote down dog whistle when when
jayapal predicts backlash in the streets
you know they say everything we do is a
dog whistle well to me that's a dog
whistle and you're telling everybody on
the left if you don't get what you want
meanwhile nobody knows what's in it and
what's not in it but all they know is
they've gotten permission to go out
there and to protest and Riot and you
know maybe she ought to worry about her
own area and her own constituents as
opposed to just reacting with this we're
going to hit the streets again because
you kind of Hope like after 2020 it was
over and it was never going to happen
again well it's not because they're
dividing us and they're signaling each
other but it's very similar to the Danny
Penny situation within a matter of
moments they're probably they're riding
the streets I'm thinking who wrote that
check to get everybody out there Geraldo
where's this heading right now do you
think that that intimidates the White
House that Hakeem Jeffrey
compared to the marine and the joking
thing it's not like the riots though no
there's no passion you're going to tell
me there's no passion for a riot over
this this is I think the general sense
it's just a synthetic but these are
politicians doing what politicians do
just making life complicated you know
what this is about this is about work
Fair versus welfare and everybody wants
people who receive welfare to do
something and there's been resistance to
that from the from the left uh
I think it's 60 percent of Americans
believe that if you get some benefit
from the government you should do
something in return and what they're
suggesting is 20 hours of volunteer work
if you're being supported in in programs
other than the usual Social Security and
so forth and that's not a big deal and I
think that it will pass and I think it
will pass because most Americans really
do believe there should be some
responsibility if you get a benefit
and we grew up 1.1 percent that's
nothing to high five about and the
president's got 33 approval rating on
the economy 38 overall this is really
going to be a blow to it but it'll help
the country in the big picture we almost
had an argument thanks for backing off
that's good you know I know I have such
restraints I know it's amazing Bon who's
part
okay thanks hi everyone I'm Brian
Kilmeade I want you to do me a favor I
want you to click to subscribe to the
Fox News YouTube page this is the only
way that I know for sure that you're not
going to miss any great commentary any
great news but fight any great
interviews coming your way on Fox you
can get it all here on YouTube so
subscribe right now